[Music]
foreign
experts hail the coronavirus vaccines as
one of Humanity's greatest achievements
[Music]
it took a matter of months as opposed to
years or decades
but we're still in Uncharted Territory
in Norway 33 seniors died after being
inoculated against covet 19.
authorities are investigating whether
there was a link
there's been the odd issue in the past
with other vaccines that's why the world
is setting up monitoring systems
watching out for side effects that may
not have been seen in big clinical
trials
still hopes are high that this is the
best vaccine in history
it's a race between injections and
infections and Israel is winning it's
inoculated a quarter of its population
scientists are closely watching to see
how effective the vaccine is when given
to an entire population and checking to
see if it's safe
this basketball stadium in Tel Aviv is
now a vaccination Center
people under the age of 35 are already
being immunized here while older
residents are getting their second jab
the vaccines are being administered in
record time
Pfizer is delivering millions of doses
in return the Pharma companies are
receiving valuable data that allows them
to measure the efficacy of their product
I don't have a problem with the data
agreement and I don't feel like I'm part
of an experiment we're leading the world
on vaccinations and Israel offers the
right kind of infrastructure
it's Israel's Health Care system with
its Universal Insurance that makes the
country so interesting to buy and Tech
Pfizer
insurance companies allocate doctors to
patients streamlining the vaccination
program
the digitalized and centralized nature
of data collection has created a
treasure Trove of readily available
information
[Applause]
one wants to understand how a real world
roll out of a vaccine program impacts
Public Health than Israel with its
digital Health repositories and its very
strong methodological capabilities and
it's a very good Outreach of Public
Health and clinical Health to all of the
citizens is probably an ideal place to
do that
the main objective is to find out at
what stage the vaccination Drive
achieves herd immunity and to figure out
ways to get there fast the data used in
the research has been made anonymous
but that hasn't stopped critics from
sounding the alarm
people are saying what's the problem
with anonymized data and the problem is
that anonymized data Medical Data today
can be transferred to be non-anonymized
if you have the right tools and the
right technology we want to have a kind
of an oversight experts that will make
sure that this data is not going to be
exploited later by Third parties
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu has
emphasized that the findings will
benefit the rest of the world
but his Prime Focus is the impact that
the vaccination program is having in
Israel itself
we will be the first country to defeat
the pandemic
the deal I have struck with Pfizer
allows us to vaccinate everyone above 16
by the end of March
the ambitious Target coincides with
parliamentary elections which Netanyahu
is hoping to win
but while the number of vaccinations are
shooting up so too our infections a Race
Against Time that Israel is determined
to win
still we don't know how long immunity
lasts and if there are long-term effects
but let's look at the immediate effects
with home curve from the German
Association of research-based
pharmaceutical companies I asked him
what I should do if I get a headache
fatigue or other symptoms after the
injection
well it's absolutely normal to have some
transient mild reaction to a vaccination
like the ones you've mentioned or raised
temperature for a while this sort of
thing so if you experience that you
probably don't have to do anything but
just wait for a moment but if it's
longer lasting or if it's more severe
the best thing or the important thing to
do is really report it to the doctor and
make sure that your possible side
effects get reported to the authorities
what would be more severe or serious
side effects that enforce a regulator to
say Act
well if they are more if they are more
prolonged really they don't go away
and of course they really have to react
to reports when it uh when the symptoms
need hospital treatment or if they are
in in some way really threatening
okay so this is all being monitored but
what about in countries where there's no
reliable safety monitoring going on
this used to be a huge problem but uh
there's been progress in recent years
the W uho the World Health Organization
has worked with Partners to do to create
a so-called mad safety app that's an app
that can be used on uh on mobile phones
and this enables everyone to report side
effects and so because many even poorer
countries nowadays have mobile phone
networks this is really a way how to
spread a reporting system even in
resource pool settings Mr can you tell
me are the people being monitored who've
got the vaccine being given the vaccine
are they also being checked to see that
they don't get sick and pass on the
virus
this is checked this is part of the the
clinical trials to find out but it's not
as easy to find this out as it is to see
if people get symptomatic covid-19 or
not
so it takes longer to find out and part
of finding out is of course to see if
when you vaccinate people in a certain
region
does this decrease the pandemic more
than is just explained from having
certain people for themselves being
immune to the virus
in the meantime some of us are going to
have to wait a long time to get this
vaccine I mean shouldn't I just wait and
see how it goes with other people
well the disease is there uh the virus
is spreading keeps spreading keeps
mutating and we see new versions of the
virus which are probably even more easy
to contract
so for everyone who has the opportunity
to get a vaccination this is certainly a
much better option than having the risk
of getting infected soon and we're not
having to pay for it are we
well in Germany and in the European
Union the
um the the government's pay for the
vaccination
and
um in various countries uh outside EU
this is also the case but of course uh
that doesn't apply to every country in
the world
from the German Association of
research-based pharmaceutical companies
let's take a quick look at what is the
first photo of sasco V2 until now images
of the microscopic Menace that's plagued
the world have been computer generated
models but not these technicians at
nanographics a spin-off from Vienna's
Technical University have used 3D
technology to scan the virus so then
color it it gives us the most detailed
view yet
researchers hope it'll help them fight
the disease more effectively as the
actual shapes of the particles are now
clearer than before
incredible something so little and
pretty can cause so much trouble
and if that's not enough to Fascinate
you maybe Derek Williams will here's his
daily segment answering your questions
on the Coronavirus
how does the Pfizer biontech vaccine
work
I've answered this before but the
question is posted again and again so I
guess it's maybe time to go over the
details again two of the vaccines that
have now been widely approved one
developed by biontech and Pfizer and one
produced by moderna are what are called
a messenger RNA or mRNA vaccines now the
technology behind them has been at the
focus of a lot of research for decades
but but this is the first time they've
received widespread approval from Health
Care authorities unlike vaccines based
on traditional platforms ones that for
example use inactivated versions of the
virus the biontech Pfizer vaccine leads
to an immune response in the body by
delivering information in the form of a
special molecule a messenger RNA
mRNA molecules are are single stranded
chains and what are called nucleotides
that fulfill a very important function
in cells they're they're kind of the
blueprints for making proteins and act
as Messengers between a cell's
headquarters in the nucleus and its
protein building factories out in the
cytoplasm hence the name but the protein
these new mRNA vaccines encode for isn't
a human one it's a protein made by the
coronavirus and when that mRNA is
injected it causes your cells to begin
making that Viral protein and that Viral
protein provokes an immune response just
as if you'd caught covid-19 sending in
the pretty simple quick to produce mRNA
code molecules to make these complicated
proteins and getting the body to do the
work is a great solution to a complex
problem and and there are high hopes
that mRNA vaccines which seem to have
finally come into their own are now set
to to revolutionize a range of fields in
medicine
finally even in a pandemic there's
romance a British couple who were
critically ill with the virus has
married on the covert Ward nurse
Elizabeth Kerr and fiance Simon O'Brien
her ambulance driver were so sick
doctors told them it might be their only
chance to tie the knot both are still
receiving oxygen and they'll have to
wait a few days for their first kiss but
the bride says she's content to wait
we've got a wedding story that can Trump
only possible
[Music]